IT IS 5:00 IN NEW YORK CITY AND
NEW HAMPSHIRE, AND THIS IS TO BE
20 PRESIDENT TRUMP LOOKING TO
SHAKE UP THE DEMOCRATS AHEAD OF
THEIR BIG PRIMARY IN
NEW HAMPSHIRE, TRUMP GETTING
READY TO HOLD A RALLY IN
MANCHESTER TONIGHT BEFORE THE
2020 CONTENDERS FACE OFF IN THE
STATES TOMORROW.
TRUMP SUPPORTER’S LINING UP FOR
HOURS TO SEE THE PRESIDENT WHILE
DEMOCRATS ARE IN A STATE OF
TOTAL DYSFUNCTION.
THEY ARE STILL FIGHTING OVER THE
RESULTS IN IOWA.
AND NOW THEY ARE GOING AFTER
EACH OTHER.
CHECK OUT THIS BACK AND FORTH
BETWEEN SINKING SLEEPY JOE AND
MAYOR PETE.
>> HE HAS A GOOD GUY.
HE IS A GREAT MAYOR.
BUT GUESS WHAT?
HE WAS A MAYOR.
HE IS A GOOD GUY.
BUT THE IDEA OF PASSING A BUDGET
AS MAYOR OF A TOWN THE SIZE OF
MANCHESTER AND MANAGING
900 BILLION, THIS GUY IS NOT A
BARACK OBAMA.
>> HE IS RIGHT.
I AM NOT.
NEITHER IS HE.
NEITHER IS ANY OF US.
THIS IS NOT 2008.
THIS IS 2020.
>> Jesse: WHILE CANDIDATES
CONTINUE TO TEAR EACH OTHER
APART, TOP CANDIDATES ARE
WARNING THAT DEMOCRATS DO NOT
HAVE WHAT IT TAKES TO BE TRUMP.
>> THE PROBLEM HERE IS THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
THE IDEA OF THE POLITICAL PARTY
IS TO WIN COLLECTIONS.
THAT’S WHAT IT IS ABOUT.
IF YOU DON’T DO THAT, YOU HAVE
DONE NOTHING.
IT’S NOT TO MAKE A POINT.
IT’S NOT TO START A REVOLUTION.
IT IS TO WIN THE ELECTION.
I HAVE THE IDEA OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY THAT I READ
ABOUT AND I SEE ON TELEVISION,
AND THAT IS A BUNCH OF PEOPLE ON
TWITTER RUNNING AROUND CAUSING
TROUBLE.
TO SPEAK OF THE OTHER DEPRESSING
THING ABOUT THIS WEEK WAS AT HIS
BEST MOMENT, THE DEMOCRATS, THEY
JUST LOOK LIKE THE GANG THAT
CAN’T SHOOT OR RUN STRAIGHT.
IF THEY CAN’T GET THEIR ACT
TOGETHER SOON, IT IS GOING TO BE
OVER BEFORE IT BEGINS.
>> Jesse: WOW, GREG, IT LOOKS
LIKE DESPAIR HAS SET IN ON THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, AND YOU CAN’T
ARGUE.
THEY ARE RIGHT.
I CAN’T BELIEVE THAT I SAID
THAT.
>> Greg: THE THING IS THAT
THERE IS A STRONG SENSE OF
SADNESS IN BILL BARR’S VOICE, I
CAN FEEL BAD FOR THAT AND THE
SMART COOL KIDS LIKE HIM AND SAM
HARRIS, BUT THESE PEOPLE WERE
WARNED, RIGHT?
EVERY DAY FOR MONTHS ON THE
SHOW.
WE WERE SAYING THAT YOU ARE
GOING TO BE IN FOR A HUGE LET
DOWN IF YOU DON’T START
THINKING ABOUT THE FUTURE AND
PUTTING YOUR EGGS IN THE
IMPEACHMENT BASKET UNLESS YOU
DIVORCE YOURSELF FROM THAT
EMOTIONAL FANTASY, YOU’RE
GOING TO END UP --
IT IS A WORSE HANGOVER THAN
TEQUILA.
TEQUILA DOES NOT CAUSE YOU --
>> Jesse: THERE IS NOTHING
WORSE THAN TEQUILA.
>> Dana: I CAN’T DRINK IT.
>> Greg: THE ONLY REASON WHY
THEY ARE SAD IS BECAUSE THEIR
FILTER IS BROKEN.
WHY DO SO MANY SMART PEOPLE, AND
BILL MAHER IS SMART, AND THEY
STEP ON THE SAME RATE THAT WE
SAY DON’T STEP ON IT.
YOU STEP ON IT WITH OBSTRUCTION
AND COLLUSION AND CAVANAUGH, AND
WE KEEP SAYING, YOU HAVE TO
CHANGE YOUR FILTER.
THE BIG POINT THAT I FIND THAT I
THINK THE FACT THAT YOU ARE SAD
IS A SELFISH COMMENTARY, BECAUSE
THE COUNTRY IS DOING REALLY
GREAT.
>> Jesse: THAT IS A GOOD
POINT.
>> Greg: REALLY, REALLY GREAT.
BUT I FEEL SAD.
YOUR SADNESS AND EMOTIONAL PAIN
CAUSED BY TRUMP’S PERSONALITY IS
MORE VALUABLE THAN A SAFER
STRONGER COUNTRY.
AND I WOULD MUCH RATHER, I WOULD
MUCH RATHER BE HAPPIER WITH A
LESS COMPETENT, MORE WARLIKE
PRESIDENT BECAUSE THAT MAKES ME
FEEL GOOD.
THERE IS AN UNDERLYING
SELFISHNESS BEHIND THE
INTELLECTUALS THAT MAKES ME WANT
TO LAUGH AND WATCH THEM DROWN IN
THEIR TEARS.
THAT IS A JOKE.
DROWN IN THEIR TEARS.
>> Jesse: AS THE ANALOGY, HOW
DOES THE RAKE TASTE?
WE WARNED YOU.
>> Juan: I THINK YOU GUYS KNOW
THE TASTE OF THE DIRT IN THE
RAKE TEETH, BECAUSE HALF THE
COUNTRY STILL WANTS THIS GUY OUT
OF HERE.
SITTING IN NEW HAMPSHIRE, JUST
SITTING IN THE STATE OF
NEW HAMPSHIRE WHERE I SAW WAS
PLUS 60% OF THE DEMOCRATS IN THE
STATE SAY THEY WOULD RATHER HAVE
THE STATE HIT BY ME THEN SEE
TRUMP CONTINUE.
>> Greg: ISN’T THAT THE POINT?
>> Juan: OH, A SECOND AGO I
THOUGHT THE RAKE WAS EMOTIONAL.
I THINK YOU GUYS, I AM SO
CURIOUS TO SEE HOW YOU REACT TO
ALL OF THIS, BECAUSE IN FACT THE
REALITY IS THAT THE NOMINATING
PROCESS IS ALWAYS A MESSY
PROCESS, AND IT IS ALWAYS A
ROLLER COASTER.
AND SOMETIMES THE ROLLER COASTER
GOES OFF THE TRACK.
AND SOMETIMES YOU THINK JEB BUSH
IS GOING TO BE THE NOMINEE, THAN
IT IS DONALD TRUMP.
AND THEN TRUMP IS ON TAPE SAYING
AWFUL THINGS ABOUT GRABBING
WOMEN, AND YOU THINK IT IS GONE
AGAIN.
AND LOOK HOW IT WORKED OUT FOR
THE REPUBLICANS.
A REPUBLICAN PRESIDENT.
WE DON’T KNOW WHERE THIS IS
GOING, BUT ONCE THERE IS A
NOMINEE, THE DYNAMIC WILL SHIFT.
YOU STOP TALKING ABOUT THE
DYSFUNCTION.
YOU TALK ABOUT DEMOCRATS
COALESCING BEHIND A CANDIDATE.
AT THAT POINT THEN YOU START TO
SEE WHY TRUMP HAS NEVER HIT --
>> Jesse: I WOULD AGREE WITH
YOU, JUAN, IN A NORMAL CYCLE,
BUT I DON’T SEE THE DEMOCRATS,
DANA, COALESCING BEHIND ANYBODY
IN THE FIELD WHO THEY NOMINATE.
HAVE YOU GONE TO A FEW DINERS
AND HEARD A SIMILAR OPINION?
>> Dana: I WILL TELL YOU THAT
THE MOOD HERE DEFINITELY FEELS
LIKE -- THERE IS SOME
EXCITEMENT, BECAUSE ESPECIALLY
THEIR BERNIE SANDERS RALLIES.
THOSE PEOPLE ARE IN LOVE.
THEY FOLLOW HIM, THEY BELIEVE IN
HIM.
HE DOES NOT TALK DOWN TO THEM.
IT IS NOT CONDESCENDING.
HE HAS ALWAYS BEEN WHO HE IS.
DO I SEE THE ENTIRE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY GETTING BEHIND
HIM TO TRY TO OUT DONALD TRUMP?
I HAVE TO TELL YOU TODAY, I FIND
THAT VERY HARD TO IMAGINE.
BUT IF HE BECAME THE NOMINEE,
MAYBE WE WOULD SEE SOMETHING
DIFFERENT.
THE OTHER DYNAMIC THAT IS
HAPPENING HERE IS THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS COMING
TONIGHT AND GOING TO HAVE HIS
RALLY IN MANCHESTER, AND THE
BEAT WAS THE SIGHT OF HIS LAST
RALLY BEFORE THE ELECTION HERE
IN THE PRIMARY IN NEW HAMPSHIRE,
WHERE HE RAN AWAY WITH IT.
AND I THINK HE HAS A SPECIAL
AFFINITY FOR NEW HAMPSHIRE,
BECAUSE THAT WAS KIND OF THE
FIRST CONTEST THAT SAID, OKAY,
HE COULD ACTUALLY WIN THIS THING
AND BE ON TO THE WHITE HOUSE.
HE WILL BE COMING BACK TONIGHT,
AND IT WILL BE PACKED.
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN STAYING UP
OVERNIGHT.
PEOPLE FROM DIFFERENT STATES IN
ORDER TO BE HERE.
SO WHATEVER HE HAS DONE HERE, HE
HAS LOCKED IN HIS SUPPORT.
ANYBODY WHO IS INDEPENDENT IN
2016, THAT PHOTO PER
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS PROBABLY
SWITCH THEIR REGISTRATION TO
REPUBLICAN TO VOTE FOR HIM THIS
TIME.
HE ONLY LOST BY .4 PERCENT IN
2016, AND THEY THINK THAT THEY
WILL BE ABLE TO WIN IN 2020.
THEY THINK THEY CAN, I THINK
THEY WILL.
>> Jesse: I THINK THEY WILL
TOO.
KATIE, DO YOU AGREE?
>> Katie: I THINK
PRESIDENT TRUMP MAY WIN
NEW HAMPSHIRE, BUT I AGREE WITH
JUAN IN THE SENSE THAT WE HAVE A
VERY LONG WAY TO GO HERE.
BUT WHEN IT COMES TO MOMENTUM,
MOMENTUM DOES NOT JUST APPLY TO
INDIVIDUAL CANDIDATES, IT
APPLIES TO THE PARTY AS A WHOLE.
WHEN YOU HAVE THE IOWA CAUCUS
VOTE STILL BEING IN DISARRAY.
THEY CANNOT FIGURE OUT WHETHER
THE DATA AND INFORMATION WAS IN
THE VOTING SYSTEM.
THERE IS A CLOUD OVER THE ENTIRE
PRIMARY PROCESS FROM THE
BEGINNING ABOUT WHETHER THE
PERSON WHO MAY END UP WINNING
ACTUALLY WON FAIRLY.
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT THE
BERNIE CAMP WILL BE THINKING
ABOUT IF HE DOES NOT GET THE
NOMINATION AND IF THEY SUPPORT
THE NOMINEE AGAINST
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
BUT THAT TRUMP CAMPAIGN HAS BEEN
ON THE GROUND ALL OVER THE
PLACE, NOT JUST IN
NEW HAMPSHIRE.
VICE PRESIDENT MIKE PENCE HAS
BEEN IN NEW HAMPSHIRE WITH A
FUNKO TRUMP AT DINERS MEETING
AND SHAKING HANDS, AND DEMOCRATS
HAVE HAD A VERY HARD TIME CATCHI
ON ISSUES.
THEY ARE RUNNING OUT OF THINGS
TO RUN AGAINST THE PRESIDENT ON
PARADE IN NEW HAMPSHIRE HE DEALT
WITH THE OPIOID CRISIS AND HAS
DELIVERED ON THAT.
AND DANA WILL SEE THAT ISSUE,
SEE WHAT HE HAS DONE, AND DECIDE
TO CHANGE THEIR REGISTRATION AND
VOTE FOR THEM.
>> Jesse: GREG, WHEN WAS THE
LAST TIME YOU WERE ADDED DINER?
>> Greg: I FREQUENT MANY
DINERS.
ARE THERE OTHER PLACES BESIDES
DINERS?
>> Jesse: NO, JUST DINERS ALL
OVER NEW HAMPSHIRE.
>> Greg: WE NEED MORE MAN ON
THE STREET INTERVIEWS, JESSE.
>> Juan: WAIT, WAIT, JESSE.
CHRIS WALLACE AND I AND CHRIS’S
WIFE WENT TO THE RED ARROW DINER
TODAY, AND THEY HAVE PLAQUES ON
THE CHAIRS WHERE AL GORE, OBAMA,
EVEN MAYOR PETE SAT.
>> Dana: WHAT ABOUT YOU?
>> Juan: YOU HAVE TO GET UP
HERE.
I AM SAYING THAT WE NEED A
PLAQUE FOR JESSE WATTERS RIGHT
IN THE SNOW.